[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm gonna have to take you apart again
hey dove anything interesting it's exist
too
make yourself useful
so uh that was fun right
[Music]
that's your cue mate
sleep tight you know what this reminds
me of
my time in the himalayas
[Music]
you think they can't kill you anytime
they want
hey [ __ ]
[Music]
how do we always get into this
massachusetts behind me we are
witnessing clear signs
of cult activity as the locals engage
[Applause]
hey
i really hope the video was worth it
everybody
fall back people need to know what
happened
with me get me on the roof now
thank you layla you're fast oh jacob
don't even mention it
[Music]
where's the other one where'd it go
[Music]
i've been watching
oh [ __ ] dev's gonna love this one
yep don't miss
[Applause]
i don't trust me
a new one
kill me you can't break the blood traps
yeah i think there's vampire in this
really what does it taste like be
specific
like blood and death and strawberry
sun's coming up let's keep moving let's
keep moving
sure thing edgar allen bro that's a good
one
do you think things will ever go back to
normal
would you want to go back to normal not
if i still have to pay my student loans
[Music]
play it day one with xbox game pass